Transcriber: Sebile Ecemnaz Kokal
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Dünya tarihi; savaşlar,
salgın hastalıklar, göçler ve
doğal felaketler tarihidir.
Günümüzde de bu saydığım
felaketlerin büyük çoğunluğu
yıkıcı bir şekilde devam etmekte.
Tek bir farkla: Dünyanın herhangi bir
yerinde meydana gelen bir olaya ait
saniyeler içerisinde
elimizde sahip olduğumuz
teknolojiyle birlikte
haberdar olabiliyoruz.
Bunlar, fotoğraf ve videolar oluyor.
Peki bu gördüğümüz fotoğraf ve videolar
bizler için bir değer taşıyor mu?
Ya da gördüğümüz fotoğraflardaki
insanların, maruz kalanların empati
duyabiliyor muyuz?
Ya da empati duyup bu sorunları daha
minimize edebilmemiz için farkındalık ile
aksiyona geçebiliyor muyuz?
Maalesef, birçoğumuz için bu fotoğraflar
bir anlam ifade etmiyor.
Birçoğumuz bu fotoğrafları bazen görmemek,
takip etmemek de istiyoruz.
Ve “Bu fotoğraflardaki insanların maruz
kaldıkları, bizim de başımıza gelmeyecek.”
düşüncesine sahip oluyoruz.
Ama aslında pek de öyle bir dünya yok.
Alan Kurdi. Bu ismi, büyük
çoğunluğunuz biliyordur
diye tahmin ediyorum.
Bilmemeniz imkansız ama ben
yine hatırlatmak istiyorum.
2015 yılında Akdeniz’i geçmeye çalışırken
ölen binlerce insandan sadece birisi,
bir çocuk.
Peki, Alan Kurdi’yi ayıran etmen neydi?
Şunu da belirtmek isterim.
Alan Kurdi’nin o fotoğrafı,
“Time”ın “Dünyaya Damga Vuran
100 Fotoğraf Listesi”ndeki bir fotoğraf.
Çok önemli bir fotoğraf.
Peki bizim için farklı kılan
neydi o fotoğrafı ?
Bir anne ve babaysanız
çocuğunuz aklınıza gelmiştir.
Değilseniz, çevrenizdeki bir
çocuk aklınıza gelmiştir.
Yani, empati kurabilmişsinizdir.
Empati kurduğumuzda ne oldu peki?
Bu sorundan kaynaklı
yani deniz yoluyla
göçmenlerin ölümlerini
minimize hale getirmek için toplumlar
ve hükümetler aksiyona geçebildi.
Bunun kıvılcımı “empati” ile ortaya çıktı.
İşte bu noktada, benim bu fotoğraflara
bakışımı değiştiren bir olay oldu.
O olay da 2016 yılının ilk
aylarında meydana geldi.
O zaman o dönemde aslında hep
sıradan haberlerden birisiydi bu.
Bir mülteci kafilesinin kaçak yollarla
denizi geçmeye çalışırken yakalanmasını
konu alan bir haberdi.
O dönemleri hatırlarsanız
her sabah ya da akşam mutlaka
bu haberleri izliyordunuz.
Ki gazeteci ve sunucu kişiler,
bunları daha iyi hatırlayacak.
Ben de o haberi izlerken haberi şöyle
tasvir edeyim size: Bir araç içerisinde
insanlar jandarma karakolunun
bahçesine giriyor.
Akşam zifiri karanlık ve kameraların
ışıkları aracın içerisini aydınlatıyor.
O aydınlattığı anda aracın içerisindeki
kadın ve çocukların özellikle
gözlerindeki şok, korku ve çaresizlik
beni çok etkiledi.
O günün sabahında zaten sabah haberlerinde
izlemiştim bu tweeti attım ben.
Ve sonrasında düşündüm ki, ya bir şimşek
çaktı. Aslında bunu, ya biz bu
fotoğraflara bakışımızı değiştirebilirsek,
bazı şeyleri de değiştirmeye adım
atabiliriz dedim ve nasıl
yapabilirim bunu dedim.
Görsel sanat daha mantıklı geldi
çünkü bütün insanlığa
hitap edebiliyorsunuz görsel sanat ile.
Ben görsel sanatların, dillerin efendisi
olduğunu düşünüyorum,
ve o aşamada, nasıl yapabilirim
diye düşündüğümde;
ya zaten bunlar yaşanmış olaylar,
bunların karşısına bizden
bir şeyler koyabilirsem
buna bizde empati kurabiliriz.
Yani bunun önünde bir engel yok.
Aylan bebekte olduğu gibi.
Orada siz çevrenizdeki çocuk olarak
düşündünüz bunu ve empati kurdunuz
ve bu noktada ben bu fotoğrafları
dünyanın birçok ülkesindeki
foto muhabirlerin fotoğraflarını
farklı bir kompozisyon ile
bizlere göstermeye, sunmaya çalıştım
ve bu şekilde de hem bu olaylara olan
ilgimizi arttırmayı,
hem empati kurmayı,
hem farkındalık kazanmayı
hem de sonuçta insanız
ve unutuyoruz, hatırlamıyoruz
aklımızdan çıkıyor.
Yani 5 sene önceki bir hadise ya da 2 ay
önceki bir deprem bile artık bizim
hayatımızda yer almayabiliyor.
Bu yüzden bunları hatırlatmak gerekiyor
ve ne yaptım bizden bir şeyler koydum.
Bu; bazen Oscar heykelciği olabiliyor,
bazen işte fotoğraf karesi.
Mesela ben bu fotoğrafı
çok önemli buluyorum.
Bana bu fotoğraf ümidi temsil ediyor.
Gazze’de çekilmiş bir fotoğraf ve
harabe, umutsuzluk;
yıkımın olduğu bir yerde neşeli bir
şekilde çocuklarını banyo yaptıran bir
ebeveyni görüyorsunuz.
Ben karşısına ise tamamen lüks ve her
şeyin dört dörtlük olduğu ama kimsenin
olmadığı ve “ruhsuz” diye tabir
edebileceğim bir banyoyu koydum
ve bunu devam ettirdim.
Buradaki görsel gibi.
Şunu ifade edeyim:
Ben aslında bu fotoğrafları empati kurmamı
ya da daha yakın hissetmemin
sebebi Türkiye’de yaşıyor
olduğuma yoruyorum.
Çünkü Türkiye, savaş ve istikrarsızlık ile
huzur ve bolluğun arasında yer alan bir
konumda bulunuyor.
Ben aslında Türkiye'yi şu gördüğünüz
fotoğraftaki keskin ince çizgi olarak
tabir ediyorum.
Hatta bazen “Acaba biz hangi tarafa doğru
meyil ediyoruz?”u da düşünüyorum.
Çünkü bu da çok önemli bir faktör.
Çalışmalarımın asıl amaçlarından
birisi düşünmeye teşvik etmesi.
Ben bu çalışmaları yaparken Hollandalı bir
takipçim yaptıktan sonra daha doğrusu
Hollandalı bir takipçim bana şöyle bir
mesaj atmıştı: “Biliyor musunuz, ben sizin
çalışmalarınızı çok beğeniyorum
ve önemli buluyorum.
Çünkü; biz de
70 ya da 80 yıl önce
savaştan muzdarip olduk,
mülteci olduk.
Ya çok yakın bir tarih ve bundan
sonra olmayacağımızın da
garantisi yok.
Bana çalışmalarınız o günleri
hatırlatıyor, hatırlamamız gerektiğini
hatırlatıyor ve elimizde sahip olduğumuz
huzurun, refahın ve barışın, barışa sahip
olmamızın daha değerini bilmemiz
gerektiğini ifade ediyor demişti.
Ben de işte çalışmalarımda onu tasavvur
ettiğim için daha göstermeye başladım.
Asıl vurucu olan noktalardan birisi,
bir İtalyan gazeteci bana, “Sizin
çalışmalarınıza gelen yorumları okurken
fark ettim ki, Amerikan ordusunun Irak
işgali sırasında uyguladığı işkence
fotoğraflarını birçok insanın bilmediğini
gördüm ve şaşırdım.” dedi.
Yani çok yakın bir tarihte meydana gelmiş
ve önemli bir olaya ait fotoğrafı
bilmemeleri beni şok etti.
“Bu yüzden çalışmalarınızın bu şekilde
unutulmuş, hatırlanmayan ya da görmek
istemediğim sorunları göstermesi
çok önemli ve farkındalık için
çok değerli.” demişti.
Ve sonrasında “Ya.” dedim, “Aslında
çalışmalarım savaş , çatışma, mülteciler,
göç gibi konuları ele alıyor.
Bunlar bazı bölgeler için spesifik diye
tabir edebileceğimiz bir durum.”
Fakat sadece bu yok ki.
Mesela bu Hollandalı takipçimin
korktuğu, çekindiği savaştan dolayı
“Biz de mülteci olabiliriz” korkusu
bence yersiz;
eğer Almanya ile Fransa tekrar bir çıkar
çatışmasına girip savaşmazlarsa.
Ki Avrupa Birliği içerisinde
ben bunun mümkün
olduğunu düşünmüyorum.
Fakat, küresel ısınma kaynaklı deniz
seviyesinin yükselmesiyle
Hollandalıların
küresel iklimden dolayı mülteci
olması pek mümkün.
Sadece Hollandalılar da değil,
Benelüks ülkeleri de değil.
Bu; New Yorklular için de geçerli,
Venedikliler için de geçerli.
Bengal Körfezi'nde bulunan şehirler ya
da her elektronik cihazın arka plan
fotoğrafı olarak mutlaka koyduğumuz ve
imkanı olanların da tatile gitmek
istediği Mercan adaları ya da
Okyanusya’daki ada devletlerindeki
yaşayan insan, aslında
bütün insanlığı ilgilendiriyor.
“Ya.” dedim, “Ya, aslında bu sadece bizim
yani bunun onun şunun sorunu değil ki
ya da sadece ondan muzdarip değil.”
Napmam gerekiyor?
Başka konuları da ele almam gerekti.
Tabii ki ülkemizde ya da başka ülkelerde
yozlaşmış siyaset, hukuk ve
sermayedarların yaratmış olduğu
büyük problemler söz konusu.
Bu, sadece bizde değil. Kadın ve
çocuk haklarına erişememek
ya da cinsiyet eşitsizliği, gelir
eşitsizliği, hayvan hakları,
çevresel sorunlar zaten vurmuş gitmiş.
Herkesin bildiği bir şey bu.
Herkesin de söylediği bir şey.
Bunlar bütün ülkeleri ilgilendiriyor,
bütün insanlığın muzdarip olduğu sorunlar.
Ben de çalışmalarımda bunları
da ele almaya çalışıyorum.
Ve bu insanlara dokunmanızı ve
anlatmanızı ve bazen kendi
bulundukları durumu ifade
etmelerini de sağlıyor.
Şimdi şöyle bir şey var.
Çalışmaların bazı bölümlerinde
insanlar şunu düşünebiliyor:
“Ya bunlar bizlik değil, bunlar
bazı coğrafyaları ilgilendiriyor.”
gibi durumlar söz konusu oluyor.
Kesinlikle öyle bir durum yok.
Yani, örneklerle devam etmek istiyorum.
İspanya’da Covid döneminde
kadınlara uygulanan şiddet
yüzde 30 oranında artmış durumda.
Yani gelişmiş bir ülkeden bahsediyorsunuz.
Ya da şimdi açlık dediğinizde aklınıza
hemen Afrika geliyor.
Ama Afrika değil.
Gelişmiş bir ülke olan İngiltere'de
bile ayda 1 milyon çocuk
yeterli besine erişememekte.
Bunun üzerine faaliyet gösteren
vakıflar mevcut orada.
Yani sadece belirli spesifik bölgelerin
problemleri değil bunlar.
Hepimizin problemi.
Fakat ortada ayrılan nokta ise şu:
Bazı ülkeler ve toplumlar bunları
minimize edebilmiş.
Bazıları ise, o ateşe benzin dökerek
daha da harlanmasını sağlıyor.
İşte bu noktada ben sanatın
ve yaptığım işlerin
bu tezatlığı ortaya koyması,
insanların düşünmesi, empati kurması,
empati kurarak farkındalık kazanması ve
bu kazanmış olduğu farkındalıkla talepte
bulunması, aksiyona geçmesi ve
istemesini tetiklemek istiyorum ve
tetiklediğimi de düşünüyorum.
Çünkü bizim bazı şeyleri
iyileştirmemiz için bunlar gerekiyor.
Bunu nereden biliyorum?
Bu çalışmaların birçoğunu insanların,
dünyanın her tarafındaki insanların
mutlaka bilmesinden dolayı biliyorum.
Ve en önemli kaynaklarımdan
birisi, çalışmalarımın
birçok dünya ülkesindeki okullarda
gösteriliyor olması beni etkiliyor
ve düşündürüyor.
Yani sadece sizin
Ortadoğu ile ilgili değil.
Yani bu gelişmiş ülkelerdeki insanları
da ilgilendiren problemler bunlar.
Ya da Türkiye gibi ara bölgelerde ve bu
tezatlığı görebildiğiniz, eşitsizliklerin
olduğu ülkelerde görebiliyorsunuz.
Ve gelişmiş ülkelerde de
bunu görebiliyorsun.
Çünkü bizim bu sorunları minimize
edebilmemiz için empati gerekiyor
ve bu empati ile sanat buluştuğunda
benim yapmış olduğum gibi önemli bir
iz bırakabiliyorsunuz.
Ve sanatı kullanarak,
görsel sanatı kullanarak
her insanın
iz bırakabileceğini düşünüyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)